usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido recientemente diagnosticada
con cáncer de mama este vídeo le ayudará
a entender algunas de las opciones de
tratamiento disponibles
el cáncer de mama es una enfermedad en
la que algunas de las células de la mama
comienzan a crecer sin control
y los tratamientos para el cáncer de
mama pueden incluir cirugía radioterapia
quimioterapia
terapia hormonal terapia dirigida e
inmunoterapia
hay varios tipos de cirugía según el
tamaño y la ubicación del tumor
este vídeo no cubre todos los tipos de
cirugía para cáncer de mama disponibles
durante una tumorectomía se extirpa el
tumor junto con parte del tejido normal
que lo rodea
en una mastectomía total o simple se
extirpa toda la mama
en una mastectomía radical modificada se
además se extirpan algunos de los
ganglios linfáticos bajo el brazo y a
veces otros tejidos del pecho también
es posible que su médico también quiere
administrarle radioterapia
esta terapia utiliza radiación para
destruir las células cancerosas o
impedir que crezcan la radioterapia de
'las externo utiliza una máquina que
dirige la radiación hacia el cáncer
desde fuera del cuerpo
y la radioterapia de as interno también
conocida como braquiterapia utiliza una
sustancia que emite radiación a través
de diferentes tipos de dispositivos de
administración las sustancias se colocan
dentro de su seno donde el cáncer se ha
eliminado
y la quimioterapia utiliza ciertos
medicamentos para eliminar el cáncer
estos medicamentos pueden tratar las
células cancerosas en todo el cuerpo o
pueden administrarse para que traten las
células cancerosas de un área
otra opción de tratamiento es la terapia
hormonal las hormonas son sustancias que
se encuentran naturalmente en el cuerpo
el estrógeno es una de estas hormonas su
cuerpo utiliza el estrógeno
principalmente para el crecimiento y
desarrollo del útero las mamas y los
ovarios
sin embargo el estrógeno también puede
promover el crecimiento de ciertas
células cancerosas que son receptoras
hormonales positivas un tipo de terapia
hormonal bloquea el estrógeno para que
no se una las células del cáncer de mama
y así no haga que estas células crezcan
y se dividan
y la terapia dirigida es una opción de
tratamiento para los cánceres que tienen
un tipo de marcador específico en las
células cancerosas
y una terapia está dirigida a las
células con marcadores llamados her2
la gp2 es una proteína natural en las
células que normalmente promueve el
crecimiento saludable de las células
sin embargo algunas células cancerosas
tienen demasiada cantidad de esta
proteína
y esto hace que las células cancerosas
crezcan y se propaguen de forma más
agresiva que las células normales los
medicamentos de terapia dirigida están
diseñados para unirse solo a las
proteínas her2 de las células cancerosas
como resultado las células cancerosas
dejan de crecer y pueden morir
la inmuno oncología también conocida
como inmunoterapia ayuda a su sistema
inmunitario a combatir el cáncer el
cáncer a veces se puede ocultar de las
células inmunitarias que lo atacan
por ejemplo tanto el cáncer como las
células inmunitarias pueden tener
proteínas llamadas proteínas de punto de
control cuando éstas se adhieren las
otras células inmunitarias detienen su
ataque
y los científicos buscan un tipo de
medicamento de inmunoterapia que impida
que las proteínas de punto de control se
adhieran entre sí
como resultado las células inmunitarias
pueden atacar y destruir las células
cancerosas
su médico puede recetar una combinación
de los tratamientos que hemos descrito u
opciones de tratamiento diferentes a los
mencionados aquí
si tiene alguna pregunta sobre el cáncer
de mama o sobre cualquier medicamento
que le hayan recetado consulte a su
médico es importante que tome sus
medicamentos según las indicaciones y
que informe cualquier efecto secundario
que tenga